now what's going on here right there's a
there's a pattern going on and
particularly because I know something
that maybe you haven't met yet I have
intentionally paired up this question
and this question and I've also paired
up this question and this question
what's the relationship between Part A
and Part B fee ously there's a
connection to you width and you saw it
when I did the synthetic division right
when you had dividing by this what I did
when I sleep in division by was one and
then what I did in Poppaea was I put one
into the function itself okay now what
you should see is there's numbers that
you get which are in common this is
negative 10 where does it appear in Part
A right now coincidentally I also got
negative 10 here which again appeared
here do you see that okay now why is it
that those are the same is that a
coincidence now in mathematics nothing
is ever coincidence right and what's
wonderful about this is that you've got
all of the mathematics that you need to
see why this is not a coincidence okay
we didn't do it we've we've done it many
many times before but I deliberately
avoided doing it what do you go through
this division process right you've got a
let's see River terms you've got a
dividend that's the thing being divided
you've got a divisor that's the thing
you're dividing by what's this guy at
the end that's the question this is a
remainder so you get four pieces okay
once you finish the question you can
take those four pieces and arrange them
in this way right you can say here's
your what's a cool here's your dividend
right what it's equal to is and I would
like it write this down with me as well
the divisor times the quotient plus the
remainder but which in this case is
minus ten okay
now Part A that division told me that
this is true
okay that's what I get out of this in
the same way that if you do live
numerical division right you can say
okay some number is the divisor times
the question plus whatever remainder is
hanging on okay but now can you see
without actually really doing the
substance you should we are gonna do it
but you don't need to as soon as I've
written it in this form you know why I
should end up with the remainder can you
see it yet let me write it out if I put
in one everywhere there's an X in this
line okay the first thing we're gonna do
is look there's a 1-1 right there did
you see that right now you know what 1
minus 1 is it's 0 so guess what I
actually don't care what's on the next
set of brackets right cuz 0 times
anything it's gonna give me 0 right so
this entire left hand party it just
collapses it just evaporates away and
you're left with that remainder hanging
on the end do you see that ok so that's
just the remainder okay and in exactly
the same way coming over here right the
Pazzi division told us that we could
write here X but this P of X equals what
are we divided by X plus 2 times this
divide this question so x squared minus
5x plus 4 and this remainder so it sure
enough when you put in negative 2 right
thank you
do you see again it's gonna make this 0
do you notice that right so I don't care
what's he on 0 times anything is 0 and
or you get left with these good
remainder that make sense so what we
just showed here right that if I want to
know they're made on and this is really
useful for me in about five minutes
if I want to have the remainder
something I need to go through this
whole process right I can go straight to
here right I can just punch in a number
and you know tell me what the remainder
is and I don't need to
it's like sneaking puffs all the way
through here and get the last number I
think they're straight to the last
number okay this is such an important
result it gets to call a theorem that's
what happens in math with results
reporter so I'm gonna give this a name
need some space for this I'm gonna leave
that pollinate books I'm gonna use it
again missing this is called because
it's all about remainders and originally
it's called the remainder theorem so
write this nice and bold
you wouldn't box around it in a second
once you're done the remainder theorem
is if you have a polynomial P of X right
then hey like a some number like like
102 or 100 or PI or any number you like
okay P of a is the remainder where you
take that polynomial and you divide it
by X minus a they say that you take the
pilot of you like pain and when you
divide it by X take away whatever that
number was okay so you can see here in
this example P of 1 is the remainder
when P of X gets divided by X minus 1
all pay of negative 2 is that number
that's the remainder when you divide by
X plus 2 because it's X take away
negative 2 do you see that that's why
you get X plus 2 okay so this here is
the remainder theorem and what it lets
you do is it lets you rapidly without
even dividing lets you find out what the
remainder is now we did a b c and d i
want to add on to that e and f 2 very
similar questions that will show us a
special case of the remainder theorem in
fact the most important case